when I'm gonna do it bro here under
house arrest Andrew Tate is still
Accused by the Romanian authorities of
sexual trafficking and other offenses
charges he denies
the self-described misogynist has been
banned from Tick Tock Instagram and
YouTube since August last year but a Sky
News investigation has found that
YouTube pushed Andrew take content to a
13 year old's account after little more
than an hour of watching videos meets
Ollie Smith he's an average 13 year old
boy likes being made to laugh and loves
pranks and gaming his parents let him
spend an hour a day watching videos of
those things on his phone
but only isn't real this image was
created using mid-journey an artificial
intelligence program we've given him a
date of birth so that's the 10th of
January 2010. he's a profile created by
the Sky News data and forensics team to
test what videos the social media
algorithms push at him so this is an
ollie actively searching for Andrew Tate
it's just what the platforms put
so to do this properly we need a blank
slate really and this is a phone that's
been wiped in factory settings exactly
exactly that we're going to set up three
different social media accounts one for
tick tock one for Instagram and one for
YouTube shorts because those are the
most popular for a 13 year old boy and
we're also going to mimic the behavior
based on ofcom research about what a 13
year old boy would look at it's
YouTube shorts is YouTube's short video
platform designed to compete with tiktok
the First videos we saw were all
non-taped content represented in Gray
for one hour and 12 minutes in Ollie saw
his first Andrew Tate video marked in
yellow
it was talking about a boxing match
between Tate and YouTuber Logan Paul
after that the floodgates opened
Tate videos featuring Andrew or his
brother Tristan all posted from other
accounts came thick and fast it
certainly wasn't the most extreme sort
of misogynistic content associated with
Tate but the more videos we saw the more
controversial they got in later Clips he
discussed throwing a woman out of his
house I told her to clean up she started
giving me some attitude and One Bad
Apple ruins a bunch I took all
throughout the window and manipulates a
girlfriend for the camera I need you to
send me ten thousand dollars
Ollie it was only served two Tate videos
on Instagram and none on Tick Tock
however after our algorithm test was
over it was easy to find take content on
all platforms just by searching
he's not dependent on his own accounts
to post his content he's got this Army
of young boys and men posting his stuff
across a range of different platforms
and so the consequence of that is that
de-platforming him hasn't actually
helped we shared our findings with
YouTube which removed half of the
channels we discovered a YouTube
spokesperson said we terminated channels
associated with Andrew Tate for multiple
violations of our community guidelines
and terms of service including our hate
speech Policy YouTube has strict
policies that prohibit hate speech and
harassment and we remove content that
targets or threatens individuals or
groups based on protected attributes
such as their gender identity Tick Tock
and meta which owns Instagram also told
us misogyny was not tolerated on their
platforms and that they removed content
that violated their policies
still it wasn't hard for 13 year old
Ollie to come across Tom Cheshire Sky
News